hey everybody it's Mike from waterfalls
and welcome to today's video now today
is uh Tuesday January 17 2023
and you know it's quite an interesting
day honestly we we had some reports out
of Europe that the ECB May opt for a 25
basis point rate hike in March following
you know what they're expected to do a
50 basis point hike in February and you
know buns the German buns went ballistic
on the news actually e-mini is also uh
caught a bid as a result of it and you
know just looking at the normal this is
the bar chart from today all right 8 30
is right in here we sort of sold off and
then you know nine o'clock we got that
Spike up uh made that new highway sold
off from our highs that was like around
35 and quarter 35 all the way back down
to close to 4 000 okay then you know
then we just sort of traded sideways
pretty much the remainder of the session
right now in the evening session we did
break 4 000
um you know we're trading around 98 39
98 so let's take a look at some of the
interesting things in the order flow but
you know before I do you know if you
haven't subscribed to the channel be
sure to subscribe you know we're getting
up a video pretty much every single day
and you know be sure to like the video
you know I get in the you know my stroke
my ego a little bit all right so you
know going into the cash open
we were making new highs all right and
we had just made a new high right after
the cash opened then we see some strong
selling coming in you can see the strong
negative Deltas there's this magenta
color which Tommy is closing quite
strong you know towards its Min Delta
you know which is a bearish signal
um but again you know cash opened you
know yesterday was a holiday I like to
let the market sort of settle down a bit
and then it sort of pulled back around
to this 4010-ish area which is you know
pretty much right around unchanged now
we did rally back up going into nine
o'clock now at nine o'clock again the
reports on Bloomberg started coming out
that the ECB is hinting at a 25 basis
point uh hike in March and
interestingly enough the market uh
spiked up and what was interesting there
was a big big size here at 40 20. let's
highlight this price level here you can
see four thousand
um traded there now
again this Market moved pretty very
quickly you can see how the volume just
jumped up in this case it was about uh
seven times as much as the previous you
know you know five six or seven times
more in markets like uh 10 years I mean
it was like 20 times the volume but um
you know you see this big size you know
when when something comes out and you
see big size and when I say something
you know the report came out
um you see a big size you can't read too
much into it at once okay meaning
we don't know
what this trade is against and again I'm
not looking necessarily because it
happened so fast I'm not necessarily
looking for this to be
um
you know an order that is going to put a
top in the market right I mean for one
we had just been trading around 20 I
don't know maybe somebody took an
opportunity to get out of a position
that they had been long for for a while
because you know the market is starting
to you know is is you know it's at a
nice price level especially when looking
at it now trading you know 20 points uh
lower
but you know if you're just sort of
looking at it and I just want to talk
about this because you know I know a lot
of people look at a dome right I look at
a dome I look at heat Maps sometimes
um you know or the book map if you will
I I use the ninjatrader one
um you see these big sizes coming in and
you actually you expect them and more
often than not this if this was like a
normal Market condition right if the
market didn't Spike up on the heavy
volume on the UCB report yeah you'd be
looking for it to sell off but when you
see big size like that and the market
trades through it
what do you think is taking place you
know there are big buyers already in the
market because somebody just you know
people just bought 4 000 contracts right
and then above it you got a nice stacked
buying imbalance you shouldn't be
looking to get short in here you got to
go with the flow right go with the
direction that the market is telling you
it's trading in doesn't take rocket
science to say okay there was 4 000 on
the offer and this is where you know
understanding and reading the order flow
differs and other forms of analysis
because a lot of people say well there's
four thousand traded there
you know we should sell off but you see
well 4 000 got taken and then you see
more aggressive buying coming in you
know stacked buying imbalance you're
making new highs okay maybe there's
other time frame Traders coming into the
market to take it higher now again you
know I'm an intraday Trader so I'm not
looking to hold this you know for the
rest of the day you know I'm happy to
get you know whatever points I can get
out of the move
then it comes up here makes this new
high of 34. I got some very bearish
signals up in here it hits
34 I've got a Delta Divergence so I got
a new or equal high this is an equal
High to the previous Mars High
at the high of the day
so that's a with negative Delta and a
strong negative Delta at that you know
minus
1181 you know over a thousand that's
strong at your high of the day you got a
big strong negative Delta I've got a
stack cell and a balance right I've got
an exhaustion print of two contracts up
here
so I've got a bunch of bearish
information right I'm looking for this
Market to sell off it starts to right it
breaks below the low of this bar 29 gets
down to 28 and a quarter
wonderful does nothing then Jessica goes
and hangs around this area of the
imbalance so it's testing this
aggressive selling in here because it
keeps trading right around there and
again I'm looking for this aggressive
selling to hold over about four or five
bars okay and what I've found you know
what I used to do with my stacked
imbalances I used to draw it out five
price uh five bars basically starting at
the
the bar with the imbalance would be one
two three four five and if I'm still
trading right around this imbalance by
the fifth bar starting at one this is
the fifth bar it's probably not going to
work out right because what you're
looking for is the move to happen now
not just sort of hanging around here for
20 30 40 minutes and then sell off
because you're looking for that
aggressive selling to continue and if
Market keeps trading back into that
aggressive selling
and isn't really coming off then it's
probably not going to be very effective
uh from a trading standpoint
and what happens so it's going sideways
for one two three four five bars six and
again you know if you didn't get out
here and then you just started trading
back up towards the high it's not giving
you a good sign all that information
there that was bearish
you should have had the move it didn't
happen and again you know taking the
order flow to another levels is trying
to put the pieces together understand
that hey there's bearish information
this Market should sell off it's not
it's probably going to keep going
sideways or it's probably going to go
higher and what happens it just keeps
going sideways and it's just toying with
you again you know the stack selling and
balance and then it just hangs right
around there okay so you've had two
stack selling balances off the high of
the day and the market doesn't really
pull off I mean this one pulled off from
although this bar is 29 and a quarter
only pulled down to seven and a half so
not even two points then it comes back
up and lo and behold it makes a new high
okay now what was interesting is you
know you're making these new highs and
you're still seeing a negative Delta
again you've had negative Delta since
that high here minus 1100
um you're still getting some decent
negative Deltas minus 300 minus 295
minus 243 minus 432. Market's not
pulling off it's like you're up there
you got that aggressive selling it you
can just sort of sense that people are
are taking profits I don't know if
there's the people that scooped up this
4 000 contracts here at 20 are just
getting you know dumping it out up here
around you know 10 points higher at 31
who knows but then you just you still
you're just making these little higher
highs here right it trades you know 34
is the high then trades up to four and a
quarter then up to five and a quarter
and but you're still seeing negative
Deltas I mean this high this green bars
got positive Delta but everything else
around it it's negative negative
negative negative you still feel like
this Market is getting ready to sell off
it's just is is it really going to sell
off or not I mean it should have sold
off here
then you start hanging around now you're
starting to get you know another stack
selling a balance okay it trades back
into it on the second bar
okay got some positive Deltas in this
bar this bar and then another stacks on
a balance this time coming in a little
bit lower okay so now I'm still hanging
around with some nice negative Deltas
minus 1500 minus a thousand so since
that high has been made here this new
high at 9 24. you got one bar with
positive Delta
one two other bars with positive Delta
but this is a red candle with positive
Delta which actually bearish but
everything else is negative and it's not
just like negative in the sense of you
know here's minus 44 but it's minus 400
minus 200 minus 500 minus 800 minus 1500
this is your clue already by the time
you get to this bar hey you know what
yeah I should short it
um then it starts selling off a little
bit you know back down towards the 20
area now what was interesting because
you remember you had that big volume
here at 20. So you you're kind of
wondering
what's going to happen if we hit 20 you
know previous resistance should become
support and there were some decent size
there a thousand fifty nine thirteen
hundred and it got through it like
butter
um and it just trade all the way down to
11. but really you know the signs were
up here
that this Market was weak you're just
hanging around the high with some strong
negative Deltas now you've seen the
aggressive selling coming in
and then it's going to come down your
target is obviously going to be 20 but
you know if you could get past 20 it
might drop further you know I wasn't
looking for a 10-point move maybe it
moved down to 15 but it did that you
know pretty much in the same bar once it
broke 20 got down to 15.
um didn't quite hit 10.
and then just sort of hung around there
and then you know it did go you know
lower right to get down to you know the
low of the day was you know four
thousand and fifty four thousand
double o or triple zero spot fifty
and actually it did rally back up
towards the 20-ish area not you know
around one o'clock I think it got back
up there but by that time it got back up
there
it was ancient history already you know
you're not seeing at any of that size
that you saw earlier on the way up or on
the way down now really quick
take a look at ones right when this was
that nine o'clock right when the number
I'm sorry when the report hit Bloomberg
and you can see how the volume just
jumped up you know it's four thousand
you know like here's you know you're
averaging generally around you know 1100
and then boom 29 000. what was
interesting again you know it's one of
those trades where
okay so our high we're making new highs
here 805.
Divergence
okay and you get over here 848 new high
853 a new high Divergence so you within
an hour you've had three divergences two
of which have failed
so what are you thinking okay
if we could break you know the highest
48 if we could break 49
you just drop a buy stop in there
because you've already broken two highs
with divergences look for the third one
go with the momentum of the market and
the market just sort of hangs around and
then it just
shoots all the way up from 50.
all the way up to 139 even but again you
know it
it's nice to say yeah you know you could
have got all that move but you know
realistically I mean most people like
myself included we trade using an ATM so
even
you know we have a buy stop here we get
filled we automatically you know our
take profit is dropped in there by the
system and in this case it would have
you would have got filled wherever
probably you know I don't know 55 maybe
maybe a little bit higher
um and then you take profit would have
been dropped in you know what 20
20 ticks higher and you'd be filled
instantly you know it's one thing so
that was a beautiful move but
realistically if you're using an ATM it
moved happen so fast you're going to get
filled on it uh
in a blink of an eye
so you know I don't know you know today
it was interesting because it was you
know that report that came out but you
know whenever you see size in the market
try and play a little bit you know use
your
computer the one that's on your
shoulders your brain to try and put
together what's happening okay because
you know that because honestly you know
when that move happened this bar
happened it happened really quick
but you could look at that and see oh
you know what there's a big seller there
okay but
don't just look at it whether it was a
big seller there
look at it from the opposite side
if somebody bought that and they bought
it instantly
right they saw and they just scooped it
up that's bullish information that's one
of the reasons you know you want to look
at the order flow whether you're looking
at a heat map or you know a book map or
a dome you know seeing that size go
through it means something
right it doesn't just mean that yeah I
had a big seller there at 20. uh order
flow sucks because there's a big seller
there at 20 Market should have sold off
no you got to look at it from the other
side
yeah there was a big seller there and
somebody scooped it all up and now the
Market's trading much higher it's
probably bullish
right because not only did someone just
buy it you had a big seller there
someone just bought it and they're
buying everything else in the market
and you know that when you know someone
just comes in and Bullies their way
through the market buys everything
chances are it's going to go higher
which it did
and then when you're sort of hanging
around the high and you you just seeing
negative Deltas you're seeing aggressive
selling come in it's probably a good
opportunity to get short but you're
looking for the move to happen sooner
rather than later like if you're getting
short here I think this is a good
opportunity to get short but just went
sideways
okay another potential opportunity gets
short and it's going sideways okay you
got to recognize that the Market's going
sideways then when you see you know
another opportunity to get short you
know in here with all this negative
Delta right off the highs the imbalances
is the move happening I can get short
okay you just took a short here maybe
you lost a point took a short here maybe
you lost another Point again these are
not you know you're not going to be
getting short here and having to stop
way up here you should recognize that
the market is going sideways you have to
right if you can't recognize that you
probably shouldn't be Trading
and then finally you get short again and
then the move happens right that's the
move that you're looking for that's this
is the move we were looking for earlier
okay you lost a point here you lost a
point there now you got you know you've
got 10 points out of this move
so
if you guys appreciate those videos you
know I mean again you know I I do this
sort of to help me collect my thoughts
and you know talk about the interesting
things that happened in the order flow
so be sure to you know hit the like
button and subscribe to the channel so
thanks everyone I'll catch you guys on
the next video bye bye